as you know there's always more changes
that we wish we could do if we just had
a little more time we're going to leave
those as exercises to you if you want to
keep polishing it up for example for
simplicity we had all tablet sizes and
orientations use the same layout however
7 inch portrait would actually look
better as a one pane UI so you can
modify your resource folders to make
7-inch portrait use the phone layout you
could also tweak the two pane behavior
so that the stay layout is auto selected
when you first launch the app also this
should just say today instead of having
the full date that way it'll look more
like to other items as you play around
with the app feel free to make any
changes you think would help improve the
user experience